it's a bit it's a bit faded but I hope
it's clear enough for you to see the
shape of what we're looking at here what
I want you to pay attention to is two
things number one pay attention to
domain and range Dana range okay now
domain and range is really easy to work
out because when you have a function and
then you get the inverse what happens to
donate it right they swap around right
the domain of the original becomes the
range of the new one the range of this
function is nice part2 to plant you just
like we restricted the day before why is
the domain of it this where's this come
from this comes from the amplitude of
the sine function right which is
actually what Raph was talking about we
actually put in a value that was he'll I
think okay so you can notice that
there's the first thing and i'll talk
about the domain reg for the others in a
second but the other thing i want you to
have a look at is concavity okay now
when i was having a look at some of your
arm graphs there was some korean points
okay I see something is going wrong
here's the easy way to work it out in
the first quadrant in the first quadrant
just visualizing you draw thousands of
these by now what is the concavity of
sine X in the first quadrant regular
signings it's clunky down it's concave
down when you reflect across what
happens to concave e when you reflect it
adds are it turns in the opposite
direction right so this has to be
concave up because it used to be concave
down and the reverse is true here okay
so you can see that's the case here it's
nice and symmetrical it's beautiful sine
X has what kind of symmetry oh it's an
odd function so that's why its inverse
is not function now let's move on to
customers
here's Cosima's again same statement
about domain and range the range of this
comes from the domain restriction that
we got here again this minus one to one
is from the amplitude of course x and
you can see the inputs are important by
the way I would probably add in I think
this is excellent I probably add him
like a line here to come down now the
reason why i add you that is number one
so i can show I know that lines up
secondly why don't we start an end of
these points again what was significant
about them geometrically yeah yeah
you're right they're turning points
right they stationary yeah so that means
on my original function the tangents
here and he would have been horizontal
right which means the tangent here must
be vertical vertical now wish you to
look at your graph right now right if
you were to put your wall or up against
does it look tangent that isn't there
right if it's not like most people they
may come away a too sharp and angle
right which is the equivalent it's the
reverse of drawing your your cause graph
like that okay you really need to have
these gentle stationery pens just like
you really need to have these vertical
imaginary tensions and drawing that
dotted way here will help you do that
because you'll immediately see something
is wrong okay last one tenure of us I'll
tell us is pretty cool right here's 10
ms again same argument about concavity
what's the concavity of tan X in the
first quadrant it's concave up and
that's why here calm down and the
reverse is true okay we chose to
restrict the domain over here or minus
pants our pontoon Japan or two and
that's where this range comes from and
the domains right the range of the
original function here is our values of
Y which means over here that's why you
get or we're values of x one more thing
what's the gradient of 10x at the origin
one so therefore the gradient of Ted
inverse you would expect to be which is
what's right
so so there you go that's pretty good
i'm happy with that please make sure
this is the opposite era tu before you
don't want us to be vertical right
because that would be x that'll be the
cube root of x right that's why you have
that vertical tangent for that guy but
for this one we should it should be
cutting at about 45 degrees ok